what do we know about X force will be
known as well besides that we know that
Drew Goddard is writing and directing
and he plans to focus on Deadpool cable
and Domino there was already plenty of
stuff up in the air before the Disney
Fox merger but now things are even more
muddled but there's no reason to lose
hope just yet no matter what Disney
plans to do with our favorite Merc with
a mouth
all signs point toward Goddard wine
Reynolds and the rest giving us at least
one great movie featuring x-force here's
a look at all the x-force rumors and
spoilers that have leaked so far rated-r
if there's one consensus about x-force
it's that just about everyone wants it
to be rated R Ryan Reynolds told
Collider he thinks that'll be the case
but it's too soon to say with certainty
telling them my sort of wild guess would
be that it would be an r-rated movie but
again right now we're just assembling
the troops to figure out what story we
would tell even the writers not working
on x-force I sure will get an r-rating
Deadpool - writer Rhett Reese told CB
are the x-force will almost definitely
be rated R you might want to look away
for this this little piggy went back
from the dead one of their poor twos
most hilariously unexpected scenes gave
us a very messy deaths of most of the
original x-force's lineup although by
the end of the film one lucky member did
get resurrected from Devil's
post-credits time up egg but even though
Deadpool brought Peter back from the
dead it's unclear of the rest of x-force
or so lucky but Philip tan who paid
Chateau star in death for two says he
will absolutely be returning for x-force
speaking to sci-fi time predicted you're
going to see more of my character in the
x-force film son added that he's
received a lot of great fan reaction
from his death in dead Porto and he
hopes the rest of the original doomed to
line up will be returning to shattered
star might have a loophole not available
to rest of the others
Deadpool - stayed at least partly
faithful to the characters origins on
the comics so are we from the planet
Mojo world so here let me you're an
alien I guess how does that help us
that alien origin could help by bringing
shuttle Starbuck for x-force mr.
sinister
movie web thinks there's a great chance
the x-force movie may introduce us to
mr. Sinha
stur whose introduction was originally
planned for Logan before director james
mangold decided to cut him in the comics
mr. Sinister's birth name is Nathaniel
Essex a matte name has been popping up
throughout the X movies in x-men
apocalypse men from something called
Essex Corp was shown collecting Logan's
blood Essex is also the name of the
school that tortured Russell and other
mutant students in Deadpool so it's also
worth noting that the headmaster of the
Essex school has never given a proper
name referred to in the credits only as
the headmaster it could be that the
headmaster has a comeback in store
despite his fatal ending in Deadpool -
[Applause]
if he were secretly mr. sinister that
would hardly matter the villain has
survived far worse free spirited devil
the devil movies featured Wade Wilson in
a long-term relationship with Vanessa
but in the comics his sexuality goes far
beyond heterosexual longtime Deadpool
comic book writer Jerry Duggan Sasa Merc
with a mouth is quote ready and willing
to do anything with a pulse
he's flirted with heroes like Thor and
spider-man in the comics
I mean saw a little bit of this with
Wade's fixation on Colossus in Deadpool
2
[Music]
why Inverness has been clear that he
wants to explore temples pansexuality at
the 2018 San Diego comic-con he said one
of the reasons he loves working on dead
port is that they can break the usual
superhero boundaries adding that LGBTQ
representation is something he once
represented more in superhero movies
specifically through Wade since all the
unanswered questions posed by the Disney
Foxx merger mean that x-force could very
well be Reynolds last crack at the
character it may be do or die time for
Deadpool to demonstrate his romantic
fluidity on-screen a post-merger
prognosis it's a strange time to be part
of a Marvel franchise and Fox as stable
and with the Disney Fox merger official
fans are wondering about the future of
all things X if Disney proves I'm
willing to be the home of our rated
superhero movies then that would likely
mean the end of the Deadpool movie
franchise and subsequently that X force
would be a waste of time and resources
we'll just have to wait and see if
Deadpool can survive an MCU merger and
owners foul-mouthed violent glory tried
so hard to go
sleeping on you guys so much so so much
[Music]